lafarge a fait ôter le fromage et max
dubois complète ses achats au marché
fermier de saint lambert
ces manifestants il prépare ni plus ni
moins qu'un banquet pour sa petite
famille il faut peut-être un kilo des
champignons pour la farce et un
assortiment d'herbe fraîche pour rendre
grâce à la merde toutes les volailles
loi quand tu parles moi
écoute moi ma famille et mes cinq
enfants et c'est fascinant c'est quatre
pôles un passionné je cherche mes
cuisses que je veux construire
max dubois achète une douzaine doigt par
année il croit qu'il faut redécouvrir
nos volailles ancestrale loire c'est
sublime parce que c'est une viande toute
fine toute douce filamenteuses et
pâturages
si on compare avec la dinde le bout de
loi est évidemment complètement
différent parce que déjà c'est une
viande rouge et c'est beaucoup plus
parfumé mais si on combine on compare la
viande doit à celle de canard qui est
déjà plus comparable ce sera plus
délicat il moins musclée
[Musique]
en déménageant avec sa petite famille
dans un rang de g b fernande wallet a
fait le choix d'élever ses volailles de
façon artisanale
le genre d'élevage qu'on a ici on
appelle ça de les vaches au pâturage de
façon vraiment traditionnel avec deux
lois domestiques ça n'est pas de l'oie
sauvage comme l'oie blanche qu'on
pourrait retrouver dans la nature ou la
bernache du canada
on a une clientèle grandissante de
connaisseurs québécois qui débarque et
qui disent moi c'est la quatrième fois
que jean cuisine ou encore j'en fais une
par année et ça c'est très excitant
parce qu'on voit qu'il ya un intérêt qui
grandit avant la vache
ces lois qu'on a mené en nouvelle france
c'est ce qu'on a menée et dans mon vieux
livres de cuisine bio loi
[Musique]
pour renouer avec la tradition max va
nous préparer une loi entière pour
l'action de grâce voilà la belle fortune
c'est une noire de quatre kilos alors
j'ai préparé la beaucoup de farce
maintenant elle est bien faire si on met
du bar à la main toujours mais on
badigeonne toi j'ai deux shows 606
biologie max ajoute sa touche du souci
sans tranchée pour éviter que loi brûle
et ne s'assèche
puis la petite carotte comme ça qu'ils
ont carrément confire dans la peloter
j'ai besoin d'eau je n'ai de l'eau le
rôtissage convient très bien à loi il
permet de réduire la teneur en gras de
la volaille le gras est évidemment
vecteur de saveur mais au-delà de ça le
gras et sous cutanée n'est pas c'est pas
de viande persillée donc si on décide de
réduire la quantité de gras on peut
venir en enlever une quantité ou soit
l'enlever complètement
si vous ne voulez pas vous attaquez aloi
entière vous pouvez cuisiner les coupes
disponibles comme les cuisses ou les
poneys qu'elle vient ces charmantes
qu'élever seul c'est ça pèse parce que
4,5 5 400 grammes dont le fait cuire
unilatérale sur le grotte sel poivre ont
des glaces ça prend 10 minutes
pitau le meilleur repos capot regardez
c'est la beauté de cette viande
toute cette session de travail pour
si les épiceries vente des oies
seulement dans le temps des fêtes
certaines boucheries antienne dès
l'automne on est obligé par rapport les
oies on pense que c'est inaccessible
abordable je projette boeuf le hall and
à la loi est une volaille noble qui
appelle à la famille et au rassemblement
la patrimonial à redécouvrir parce que
c'est bon oui ouais merci pour le repas
[Musique]